Scottie I gotta get that review and I
need it now so this one's a patreon
sponsored review got a couple of them I
gotta get in this month I say got two as
if it's obligation actually I really
quite like getting the patreon sponsor
reviews because oftentimes the kids it
gives me a chance to talk about stuff
that I wouldn't be covering otherwise
either cuz I don't have time or it's
something that I otherwise wouldn't have
looked into in the case of this one this
is a movie that I had seen before
hadn't rewatched in a while and didn't
review when it initially came out and
that is Star Trek beyond so suppose I
should give a little bit of background
information on my own relationship with
Star Trek since that is not one of the
fandoms that I talk about the most on
here I've only kind of touched on it
geez it might only have been the Wrath
of Khan review who but Star Trek is one
of those things that has always kind of
been around for me and it's like has
been sort of my fandom adjacent and like
little bits and things in it that I like
but I've never I've never done a dive
into Star Trek I didn't really watch
much of classic at all I grew up a
little bit on next generation but I
actually haven't even seen the whole run
of that I've seen like what would what
are usually considered to be the best
episodes I've seen all the movies which
was sort of my initial hook in I had a
had a VHS copy of Star Trek 4 growing up
and I actually i fairly enjoyed the the
reboot stuff they're not perfect there
are nickels to be had and I know a lot
of long-term Trek fans cannot stand the
reboot movies except for this one now
this is going to be a slightly
interesting thing because a lot of like
serious Trek fans that I know really
really like Star Trek Beyond and I wish
I'd liked it
better so I gotta figure out how I'm
gonna go about this um first off let me
say that I think I get or at least I can
relay what a fair number of people who I
know who really like this movie
say that they like about it which is
that a lot of them seem to feel that it
is the thing that they kind of always
wish the show was and what I mean by
that is plot wise in terms of general
structure it feels like it could be a
story that would be an episode of you
know the original show a two-parter
maybe but it feels it feels like an
episode of the show done with the budget
and the scale and the technical
abilities that the show couldn't even
begin to dream of which you know doing a
big-budget version of the show is oddly
not something that the Star Trek movies
have ever really been and definitely not
we are talking the original cast and the
continuation of the original series
because that was always what the movies
were they were a continuation of the
later era of the career of these people
they never really tried to do the let's
do that thing we used to do on TV but
blow it up up to screen size didn't
really do that they took those
characters and then tried to do
distinctly more cinematic things with
them so if you're a longtime fan of Trek
especially you know classic original
Star Trek I get why this is a big appeal
for you because I like I have nothing
against original Star Trek but I've only
I've only seen like again the some of
the most well-regarded episodes but I
was never really heavily into it
excessively I don't have that link in
and as a result I tend to I tend to do
that thing that I do sometimes which is
to over focus on the things that don't
quite work for me and yeah professional
buzzkill but before I get to that stuff
let's talk positive stuff so I've
always like this cast I think that this
cast topped the bottom is really good
for these parts and like I could name
everybody but I mean I literally mean
every single member of the Enterprise
crew is really good on this
it certainly is I think the best-looking
of the three reboot Star Trek films made
it excuse the lens flares that JJ Abrams
was so popular up and it also feels like
it makes better use of like a for lack
of a better term move camera moves that
feel like they're in space that feel
like they are messing with gravity that
give you a sense of scope and of things
I think sometimes I kind of wish the
camera would calm down a little bit what
it's just two people talking and yet
it's still kind of swooping around the
place sometimes but you know for the
scenes that are not the quiet scenes it
works really really well director Justin
Lin brought a lot of visual visual
acumen to this and it's a very
good-looking film and there's a lot of
cool concepts in it as well I like the
whole presentation of sort of the swarm
of ships that the that the villains used
and I like the fact that like none of
these have weapons on them but the
reason it's deadlies because there are
so many of them and they can just crash
and into you and tear your ship to
shreds that's really cool and really
intimidating they do an interesting job
of giving most of the characters you
know a good bit of something to do
because you know they they sort of
divide them up so we've got you know the
teams get split up we've got Spock McCoy
that's always a fun pairing we've got
Kirk and Chekov wouldn't have
necessarily thought to pair them
inherently but they work pretty well
together
we've got Scotty and a new character who
they're really good she's doing a little
bit of a generic sort of aliens you know
super literal not quite getting English
quite right thing but she plays the part
really well so it still works for me
and Sulu get a little bit of the short
shrift because they're basically just
captured but they still do you know
these are both still very good actors so
they do well with the parts that they're
given and structurally it gives us you
know a way to sort of keep an eye on all
the different moving parts of the story
because we can go from each of the
different groups as well as giving us a
chance to highlight and single out these
specific characters so all of that works
pretty dang well - so one of the thing
is a bug leo about this movie i'm sorry
i put it off for as long as I could so
this movie did a thing that I've run
into before it this is not the only
movie I've ever encountered this but
I've East for me it's them it feels like
the most egregious which is that it
feels like we skipped a movie and what I
mean by that is it opens and we get
Kirk's Captain's Log and he's three
years into his five-year mission and
kind of jaded kind of ready to be done
now that is by no means an invalid story
to tell with Kirk you can certainly tell
that story and honestly this is a pretty
good telling of a story with him in that
state why that bothers me is in the
second one in into darkness he was so
excited to go off on the five-year
mission he was so pumped for that that
that was what he was gonna get to do and
in many ways it felt like in the
darkness was this is the last thing that
he's gonna have to deal with before he
gets to go off and do the thing he wants
and we come in at the start of this
movie and he's already kind of over it
and done and jaded and I feel like we
missed the movie where he's just
exploring and just doing what he wanted
to do and enjoying it for a time it's it
annoys me again it's not it's not a sin
on the same scale but it annoys
for the same reasons that like when a
film pivots on like the two characters
getting and you know getting in or
saving a relationship and then there's a
follow-up film and it starts out and
they're already broken up it's like well
what what was the point or you know the
really extreme example again this is
harsher but I still feel like it rings a
similar bell the Alien franchise Ripley
goes through all this stuff to save new
and then we open the next film oh and
look she's dead you know it just it
feels like it it negates or or skips
over or kind of brushes aside a lot of
what the character was fighting to get
to do and we never got to see him just
do it so and the fact that that happens
right off the bat
always it's it's ours me on the film in
the first few minutes which is annoying
like and I don't mean it's annoying that
it's in the film it's annoying that it's
ours my experience as much as it does
it's annoying that my brain can't let
that go because like I said there's no
reason you can't tell that story it's
just for me we're missing another one in
between before we get to that point so
that's one thing and again you know if
it works it's thematic it's all that
stuff I also don't really like the
villain for a couple of reasons the
first is like a fair number of the movie
villains basically really except for
Khan
general Chiang and the Borg the villains
have never really been much to write
home about in most of the Star Trek
films I mean they they just haven't and
I don't think crawl does a lot to
reverse that trend first of all it's
it's a waste of idris elba they bury him
in this makeup for most of it and
yeah I mean he he's not he's a good
enough actor that he doesn't get lost
behind the makeup but I feel like I
don't get a sense of what he actually
brings to the table I feel like the
performance that we get is not
dissimilar from what any you know
Klingon of the week performance would
have been on next generation or ds9 so I
mean that that doesn't help and then
when we get the twist that I get
spoilers I suppose I'm about to get into
when we get to the twist of who crawl is
and where he comes from I part of me
isn't it picking on it because I feel
like that's a big leap that they really
don't explain how the heck that kind of
happened like how he went from a human
captain to this and why he had he
adopted a different name and why he's
speaking in a language that is not
English like I did it doesn't totally
derail me I'm like I guess somewhere
along the line there is an explanation
but the movie doesn't have time for it
and it's a big it's a big ask to get the
audience to go with you on that but I
think and I did honestly I didn't peg
this until I rewatched it this time I
think what I dislike about it is and and
this is not the only film I've seen this
sort of thing in I dislike this
characterization of soldiers as being
not only unable to leave the battlefield
behind but very vehemently unwilling to
leave the battlefield behind that they
only find meaning in combat and in war
and they will kick start that up again
so that they can have purpose and like
I'm not gonna say that the people like
that don't exist in life they do but it
it's one of those things where I feel
like ice
I see it way more than I'm comfortable
seeing it like as a trope it it feels
like whenever you're dealing with a
villain with a military background like
a formal military background you used to
work for the quote-unquote good guys
things like that you it's so often you
get you know we never should have
declared peace or the peace wasn't worth
it or in the case of crawl like without
conflict there's nothing that defines us
and gives us strength and I guess I I
just feel kind of inherently
uncomfortable with how frequently I see
that characterization for soldiers and I
mean it's one thing when you can address
it like more properly with you know and
link it to something like PTSD or
whatever but it the way it plays out
here it almost feels like it's taken for
granted that yeah
soldiers are like that like his retort
to Kirk for why he has to do this is I'm
a soldier as if being a soldier doesn't
means you can't be a peacekeeper I don't
know it just kind of bugs me that's not
like an angle that I I have a ton of
insight into I was never in the military
and I mean my grandfather was but that's
not really a part of my my immediate
family history either so I don't stray
speaking I don't have a dog in that race
but it's still I don't know it just
doesn't sit right with me so that's the
other thing on that and it is a shame it
it annoys me that basically these two
and really kind of only these two things
bother me about this movie because I can
watch it and see all these other things
clicking into place all the interactions
working really well heck I don't even
like the song sabotage that much but I
really I get a big grin the way it's
used it comes back in this film and you
know the performances are fun and the
interaction is great and the banter
McCoy is awesome and there's all this
really good stuff but these two elements
really do pull it down for me and
neither of these issues makes this a bad
movie it just makes it one that I I feel
like I should be enjoying more than I am
and I wish I did enjoy it more than I do
so I guess that's where we land I really
hope that the patreon who sponsored this
isn't mad at me because I I get worried
sometimes when I get when I want to get
patreon sponsor things for for things
that I'm like oh I'm not gonna have the
nicest things to say about that well I
mean I think sometimes they actually
very much deliberately want to see me
kind of try and make sense of stuff I
think that's how I ended up with the
Transformers the movie last month but
yeah I'm gonna be honest whether it's
sponsored or not I've got to be honest
so Star Trek beyond what did you think
about it whatever your thoughts are drop
something down in the comments let's
talk about a whole bunch of stuff you
can do I mentioned the patreon several
times because this is a sponsor review
so there's a link to that plus there's
buttons and there's a whole bunch of
other links as well and there's a peel
box and all sorts of stuff check it out
if you want to but you know what if you
don't
don't sweat it because at the end of the
day you're the council I just run the
meetings and until next time this
council is adjourned
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]